prende tutti ragazze provenienti questo
video sono fa vigenti sono su morphy nei
100 m ecco bravo zia complimenti e mi
piacciono l'inizi che cosa sta
succedendo due le civiche non è quale
quello maschio
ah no è un maschio dove sono morti sede
che non vi piace la discoteca lega
anch'io quando sono in discoteche ballo
sono triste donna che non ci credo
funzionano gli specchi mica è rarissimo
torno un gioco in cui l'anziano di
specchi che bello che sono durate
ragazzina di minecraft l'ombra e così
pixellosa cazzo treni f per pisciare 10
su 10 gioco dell'anno
voglio proprio sapere come hanno
registrato gli effetti sonori di stop
vista parte del gioco bene bellissima
hai finito che cazzo sei migrante che è
bello diventato buio ma che peter yuhara
loser chi è che mi dai del perdente
loser siamo per caso finiti in donnie
darko che bello è figo non vi fate
uscire per cortesia grazie avanti ziober
anzi ti apro io sono uscito sono uscito
mente perché non addio che cosa è
successo
voi cosa vi interessa guarda credo sia
giusto il caso di niente lo zio cambia
spacciatore comunque zio è la la morfina
serve per varare lei troppo ci si è
fatti né che vogliono né per ore con un
dettaglio permesso c'è un [ __ ]
coniglio scalve buon coniglio che bella
giornata le big love her che cosa fa
parkour c'è un coniglio partono i
ragazzi e zio mi hai portato all'inferno
tana all'altra pigna e lo sapevo lo
sapevo avrei scommesso male pdl in sua
scuola puliscono se ne sbattono il cazzo
ragazzi non ho capito senza semi fb
progetto va bene che in skyrim ho fatto
pratica con skyrim ragazzi sto
perfettamente come scassinare l'altro è
alle stesse dinamiche dello
scassinamento di
calmati te 2 ma portato vi fate uscire
grazie la porta questa era aperta
soltanto dall'esterno
devo trovare un altro modo per aprirla è
che ne so cosa devo fare un ferro di
cavallo ferro di cavallo sulla porta
certo eccolo qua con quale criterio
spiega avvicinano i conigli ora poi
sbloccare la porta per questo ho trovato
serve quali tira le palle inutile che
non tanto non c'è il pene frate
chiazzolino c'è una cosa seria ascolta
frate guarda che io c'ho i ferri di
cavallo qui è che fa seri di me non mi
sei più simpatico fatelo dire perché se
non è altro se che ciao piacere sono sta
minkia turati siam tornati qui a scuola
dalla benna zio michè droghe ti fai c'è
una si scende ancora la scritta luserna
basta
ted ted dio ti prego non bulli zar
mimaki ed credo che ted sia questo che
mangia con la [ __ ] perché il figo mangia
sempre con la figlia ma questo è un
cesso di merda vedete è la storia di uno
che è sempre bulli dato e quindi qualche
modo si fa di morfina
grazie svolta fra tema ti senti bene
perchè ti vede un po pallido oggi non lo
so se magari era impressione mia sede
che al cibo della mensa ragazzi
fatalmente cagare che la gente da di
stomaco diventa così amico mio da oggi
va il grigio di moda non hai capito un
cazzo c'entra o perfetto ho trovato
questo qua va bene magno da solo ma va
bene perché tanto c'è gente che ha detto
ciao sono amy e non ho potuto non ho
saputo neanche rispondere beh mi chiama
[ __ ] poi se magna pure il dito cioè via
questa vuole il bene
è losers figlio di [ __ ] maragall
importante non è questo che uscire che
devo fare
posso suicidarmi nell'iperspazio ci ha
pensato il coniglio ragazzi ci ho
pensato coniglio a farmi cadere nei
conigli di conigli di merda cioè
esistono le cuffiette 0 sappilo che ti
sotto gli accendini a non fuma nessuno
qui va beh tutti su cui telefoni e
mezz'ora che cessa canzone una minchia
finito a sé messo a piovere a mezzanotte
31 batteria scarica
ciao jane che sei game è la ragazza
quella che mi aveva parlato a mensa game
cosa cory jane l'iraq che questo è
diventato sede renderman gran data c'è
la caverna di batman qua sotto ragazza
diventando tutto in bianco e nero batman
confirm cioè ragazzi e batman e batman
adesso spunta joker
ciao joker messo mazza che allegria ma l
lane bianchi a most a casa primo grado
era un consiglio era solo un consiglio
fate quello che minchia volete fate
uscire cosa picchierà uomini nudi e ci
sono uomini nudi neri che corrono devo
uscire da questo la nato corso bravo
bravo che ebbe l'idea dal letto o una
botola apri apri apri veloce veloce
grandissimo chi è che ha aperto la
finestra da dallest in avanti ragazzi
pipistrelli sanno aprire le finestre e
una cosa che ciao sono sceso qua sotto
dispiace non le dispiace è una roba jane
sei tu jane la madonna che gioca jane
ascoltami e forca [ __ ] che figo e
ciarcià proprio tipo ha visto
l'esorcista ieri si vede che voleva
a fare il provino ci sono i primi tanto
chi se ne fa ormai vivi strali siano
diventati amici talmente tanti che fotte
sega quindi posso grazie
sono uscito a jane dove sei sono usciti
tra tratto che posto era che posto
brutto ma non c'erano uomini nudi che
correvano fuori prima tutti mi hanno
sentire alì tate nelle orecchie però
questo è un altro discorso ragazzi anche
non fare robe tipo paranormal activity o
esorcista o qualsiasi cosa anche detto
abbiamo calma molto calma che giorno
meraviglioso peter è veronica che
giornate veliche sole splendente che ci
rende jane hai mai pensato di fare le
previsioni del meteo la prossima
è cascato un frigo pane dal cielo luce
anche voi maledetti inscritte loser luca
è arrivato un frigo dal cielo foto e
sega siamo in teatro posso unirmi a te a
guardare lo spettacolo che dovrebbe
essere tipo la cosa che farlo grease
sei pronto per il gran discorso zio
ragazzi e ragazze sola mamma [ __ ]
bravo bravo questo volevo sentirti dire
bravo 0 ma cosa sono io
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma perché ma perché va perché perché
ragazzi spiegatemi perché jane
ma fatemi essere fatte viaggiare potenza
è ok
sono stato jane si corsa da me perché ho
fatto schifo al pub e nelle
interrogazioni sono più o meno uguale
cioè dico sembra stesse cose ma perché
piangi sempre ma così problema acciaio
[Musica]
ok questo era il richiamo degli avatar
sai piange ma perché piace è tutto così
come inizia a poi si è fatto di morfina
perché capito di essere un perdente a
caso e ha deciso di farsi morfina giusto
giro di sofia gatto in mano lo stesso
club è grazie a lei mi spiegate nessun
senso è tutto quello che ho passato
finora perfetto poche parole è successo
tra l'altro la cosa dell'esorcismo
ancora l'hanno capita però è ok
questo è tutto ciò che è successo adesso
sono in bagno e così è iniziato tutto il
gioco perfetto e quindi con la pistola
in una mano la morfina nell'altra fammi
capire cos'è quali sono i tuoi intenti
spiega mi prendi l'arma perché chicche
che carico e carico questo non siamo per
rompere il culetto a qualcuno anche se
lo merita ragazzi il problema è che non
dovrei farlo così ma dovrei andare
semplicemente di schiaffo in faccia ci
siamo ragatzu ali
non c'è posto per te
madonna no no voglio colpirlo colpisci
non colpiscilo grande grandissimo sono
test ammazzano reati siamo ragazzi chi
siamo dove ted che balla fatemi capire
levati di torno a un tizio a caso la
famiglia sono diventato un box rails
dove ted sta parlando con la mia ragazza
ormai dio cosa vuoi loser cosa c'è in
mano vendetta
ciò la vendetta è un anno zero è vero
che si manifesta la mia nuova
videocamera voi vedere come funziona
sarei di questo ben self piace bella zio
bel no narrativa no ma no che me frega
latifah patti parola chi che cosa mi ha
fatto fuori non mi fate spagnola dati ma
non voglio scala relativa basta solo a
lui solo a lui
vabbè spariamo la tipa contano che cosa
ha fatto sapere la cristiana che cosa
c'entra sono spaventati tutti un
coniglio ancora lui al coniglio parkour
fantastica corri cosa che coniglio
parkour è un genio corre corre corre
corre tanto non ce la fai a salvarti
prova benni porta è stato bello ma
perché ci sono tipo a caso cosa c'entra
ci sono altri nativa è così perché c'è
un coniglio non riuscirei mai più a
ridere neve perché rideva sempre
effettivamente però che possa uccidere
basta che lo uccidi è la figura che
bella faccia che c'è perché io sono te
stesso ted come sono tre stelle
che cosa su cosa vorrei mi sono ucciso
ok dopo quindi mi sono suicidate e basta
perfetto che cosa bruttissima mar fine è
finito così un gioco di karim khan
bazaar
ma che cosa mica ti sei fumato ragazzi
concluso vile episodio spero che video
vi sia piaciuto è stato è stato figo in
realtà è stato veramente figo 9 banane
20 ragazzi se vi è piaciuto così tanto è
un mi piace anche a pagina di facebook
con il video tra tale iscrizione
se avessi di scatole ci vediamo passioni
dove ragazzi